foreign
[Music]
hello Barstool Sports I'm adam22 here
with
A.D house phone and today we're going to
answer the internet's most amazing
questions or something would you rather
give up music or porn oh oh my God a
little dirt
I only really got into watching porn the
last couple years yeah I didn't used to
watch it that much you've been watching
off to my mind because I [ __ ] so many
girls honestly in my life like I know
you guys can't relate but I've gotten so
much [ __ ] in my life that it's like oh
I don't really need to watch porn I can
just think about like what I did last
Tuesday
but now I'm like you've been watching
porn since 1995.
watching it if you get rid of porn like
you don't have plug talk you don't have
that whole [ __ ] industry
I thought you were just talking about
consumption no we're talking about your
business so you're asking which one I
can make more money of goodbye porn yeah
I guess really yeah I think so yeah
really yeah I thought she's gonna say
goodbye no jumper no that's good for you
guys yeah right would you rather be
blind or ridiculous
blind for sure Ray Charles movie he had
a whole bunch of [ __ ]
but you don't even know what they look
like for real I mean you probably it's
an imagination uh no I'm gonna give up
the dick now that I've had like a minute
to think about it yeah it makes sense
yeah you need your eyeballs also I have
such a big dick that it would be kind of
a burden to get rid of it you know it'll
maybe make each life easier if you can
be homeless in any City where would you
choose Seattle Los Angeles Los Angeles
because you can just lay down anywhere
I'm going up to Seattle because it's
clean and then white people up there are
friendly they'll give you money he
thinks that if he goes there antifa's
gonna take care of them
how long would it take you to eat your
own body weight and hot dogs six years
400 pounds of hot dogs
how much is a hot dog like a pound I
feel like we're talking about like 500
hot dogs four Hot Dogs full oh my God so
that's a thousand hot dogs
I mean all day him all day all day right
all day damn two hours four hours maybe
you're the biggest Glizzy gobbler of
everything
it's gonna take me like a whole year nah
three a day nah how many could you do a
day 10 a day you just said you could do
like 20 a day no no no no you said the
other day if you pop this in you could
you could hold every hour you could be
in a hot dog eating content I could get
in the Xanax coming in 100 hot dogs in a
day yeah that's real
no but I think I could eat 20 a day and
kind of enjoy it that's cool who would
win in a battle royale 30 midgets versus
one full-grown lion
the Lion's gonna oh my God the Lion's
gonna Dimensions you can put 30 shocks
against the lines
30 Shacks how about uh a lion would take
out 30 Shacks they're crazy yeah yes I'm
sorry Shaq you're done if you see me
fighting a mountain lion you better help
the mountain lion if they got if they
got weapons they might have a good
chance I think a lion could take a 30
midgets with machetes yeah if you got
ten thousand dollars a day for every day
you didn't masturbate how many days
could you last Adam
yeah I'm gonna have a wet dream after
like a month I'm gonna have 300 Grand
and then I'm gonna have a wet dream and
it's all gonna be worth it Adam is not
gonna make it past one [ __ ]
um
how long could you go forever
yeah if you couldn't [ __ ] if you
couldn't [ __ ] I mean it's good after a
couple weeks it's gonna start getting a
little tough but I I mean still can I
slide up and down on the bed until I
come no can I [ __ ] a couch cushion if
you're live depending on it what
gymnastics event Would You Bet Your Life
that you could do I would bet my life
that you would fail in all of us
what about the one where like the two
things are there you like or
my arms work still the Rings what about
the [ __ ] you throw the [ __ ] that's
not gymnastics it's not even close oh
all right if you can see a sex tape with
any two movie characters who would it be
oh James Bond what and you got to get a
guy and a girl okay James Bond and uh
Cruella Deville
one is fiction
Wonder Woman and Iron Man okay Adam has
never watched a movie he doesn't know
names
is it embarrassing for a man to get
manicure pedicure if I do it [ __ ] I
just got one [ __ ] you talking about
hold on
[ __ ] are we talking about [ __ ] are we
talking about he's really taking a sock
off what are we talking about [ __ ] my
[ __ ]
remember
[Applause]
next time
you see I got my [ __ ] done I didn't get
smacked up who is your white whale guest
for no jumper
I am the white whale probably Brian
Pumper the most legendary porn star of
all time I'll say Kanye West
damn I feel like that is I mean like
attainable I mean Kanye does do
interviews with everybody but now when
you go in barcelon say he's a maniac so
you probably wouldn't do whatever with
me yeah
yeah I mean I went to this compound in
Wyoming
like
the most epic guest I could ever have
would probably be KFC oh that's a great
or Dave Portnoy dick riding dick right
there you go Dave let's get that in I'm
gonna use your platform to throw that
out there look at me
Ariel or Jack
I'm gonna have to say
racist [ __ ] who the [ __ ] is
Jasmine
you can't imagine that there's a main
character no I know who I Know Who Ariel
is but I don't I didn't know who Jasmine
was no now I know who it is because
y'all said it but in my head I'm like
what the [ __ ] is Jasmine Potter
because she has a adult vagina I'm
pretty sure because Ariel has just like
fins and [ __ ] yeah fin [ __ ] might be
busting
no I [ __ ] a fish before it's nothing
to write home about yeah it's probably
good you've never seen people [ __ ]
fish
[ __ ] it that's crazy I went to like a
weekend like retreat where you [ __ ] a
bunch of fish
does that mean are you serious yeah
I'm out of here it's like you meditate
and you go through it and then you [ __ ]
a fish yeah where you met Peter Gump
yeah
what the [ __ ] Adam you [ __ ] fish what
I genuinely hope that
thank you for watching answer the
internet please subscribe to the channel
comment below on other celebrities you'd
like to see and make sure you hit the
Bell to get notifications when new
episodes come out